Speaker 1: Let's go next to Vahan from Orlando,
Florida, that I pronounced that correctly.
Speaker 4: Yeah, can you hear me, David?
Speaker 1: I can hear you fine, Vahan.
Speaker 4: All right, so I was just wanting to ask
a question about the infrastructure bill, please,
because we have the bipartisan one that has 17
GOP senators and is very likely to pass. But I'm
concerned about the reconciliation package. And
Senator Manchin has said that there's no chance
it's there's no guarantee it's going to pass.
And Senator Sinema has said that she's not going
to cancel her vacation plans to vote on this
package, which I object to. But it is what it
is. Do you think the reconciliation package
has any realistic chance of passing into law?
Speaker 1: I have no idea. And I see really? No. I
mean, we'll know soon at this point that this type
of prediction to me is not super interesting. Like
maybe you know what? I don't really know. I think
the more important thing on this issue is the
entire framing of this infrastructure thing as,
oh, how do we pay for it? Can we afford it? What
really counts is infrastructure. If if people so
there's progressives who want to do infrastructure
for its economic stimulus and so on and so forth.
Every right winger who is of the mindset of USA,
no one should be begging for this infrastructure
package because you look around the world and
you look at American public transit, it's a joke.
You look around the world and you look at our top
airports, they're a joke. You look around the
world that broadband access and then you see
the United States. It's a joke. Forget,
you know, bridges and tunnels. Of course,
if you are in America first, America needs to
be the best thing. How on earth you justify
not doing this infrastructure deal. It's the
terms on which it's being discussed are crazy.
Left and right should be completely united on
this. And getting this done could be for different
reasons. Who cares? And the entire you know,
I'm sick of the Joe Manchin and cinema stuff.
I'm sick of the Republicans who are just like,
oh, we don't have money. We don't have a hold
on a second. This is first of all, we do have the
money. Secondly, it's so economically stimulative
to do this type of stuff, it's just crazy. So
to answer your question, which I'm not really
answering, I have no idea in hell whether the
reconciliation version has a chance of passing.
But these people better pass something because
the country is desperately in need of it.
Speaker 4: Yeah, that's that's totally correct.
And we badly need that infrastructure package.
Thank you for taking my call, David.
Speaker 1: My pleasure. Really great
hearing from you. I'm going to take
some more calls, but in a moment,
I'm going to take a very quick break. Just hold
on and then I'll be right back with everybody.